well the civil war began more than three
years ago after Houthi rebels who are
Shia at Muslims supported by Iran took
control of parts of the country
including the capital sana in an effort
to support the internationally
recognized government Saudi Arabia and
its coalition of mainly sunny Muslim
nations launched airstrikes that
coalition is backed by the UK the US and
France but nearly 50,000 Yemenis have
died in combat and many more have been
killed by famine and disease Sky News is
the first international broadcaster to
visit asslam in northern Yemen where
people are starving a Middle East
correspondent acts Rossy traveled to
harsher province a warning that his
report contains distressing ill images
of severely malnourished people they
emerge from the refugee camps dotting
the countryside hands outstretched their
desperate
you can tell from the way the children
stare that no one comes here and no one
is helping we were told Yemen's crisis
was the world's worst still didn't
expect this the families existing here
to see their suffering this man shows us
he hasn't eaten if there is food the
children eat first and scrap over
whatever they're given we move to
another camp and again we're immediately
approached we've been here for about 10
minutes been surrounded by people
telling us that they don't have enough
to eat and they're bringing us what
they're having to survive on these are
just plants that they find around the
camp just so they have something to put
into their stomachs and you were telling
me that they're boiling this up yeah
yeah first they boil this kind of trees
after boiling they add some salt and
they eat it without Britain without
anything Yemen is facing a catastrophic
famine but here it's already happening
Garwin is boiling up leaves for his
family I have to do this he says so my
children don't go hungry the only
Hospital for miles around is overwhelmed
the simply aren't enough beds in the
epicenter of Yemen's crisis doctors say
a mall her name in Arabic means hope is
close to death her breathing is very
shallow she's seven years
no money no clean water no food she's
just one of hundreds of thousands of
Yemeni children sick from hunger Yemen
is dying in a war that appears to have
no end
fuel shortages have ravaged the economy
the country has been broken by years of
fighting and a sea and air blockade by
the saudi-led coalition airstrikes on
infrastructure have cut off entire
regions Saudi Arabia's fight against the
Houthis has exacted a huge cost on the
civilian population
he's definitely totally preventable and
actually the the course of this near
famine or pre famine situation in which
we are is obviously the war if the
conflict continues this country is
going into the Arby's further no partner
[Music]
but families affected by this war say
they've already entered that dark place
[Applause]
[Music]
sure here has just arrived at the
hospital he's three years old but weighs
half of what he should the war is
killing Yemen's children slowly there is
patient who died like under an animal
after a man from Mars he is 2 years and
his body weight is only 5.5 kg and
doctors say the crisis is about to get
worse
the World Health forget human and they
they put us in this situation because it
is not possible to see this in this time
2018 and we have severe acute
malnutrition in Yemen what do you want
them to do
what do you want the world to do I
wanted the world to stop the war at
least at least they have to provide food
for the enemy and if that doesn't happen
we'll see more and more they will die we
will we will see people will die they
will die and we will not exist as
enemies make no mistake this is a
man-made catastrophe in which Britain
has played an active part arming and
providing military support to the
coalition
and if the bombs do not stop falling
millions could die in what was already
one of the world's poorest countries
Alex Rossi Sky News in Hajer province